[Music]
are we live we're live we are live
we're live yes we're not live
we are live welcome to the mario kart
deluxe eight in-houses in in office
stream well that's a good intro cause
we're live
my name is rob handler next to me is
joey
and we will be commenting over once
again our first in house office
tournament for mario kart 8 deluxe
wow
this is going to be fun
interesting i'm good good i'm doing very
well thanks
uh yeah so we're gonna get right into it
uh how this is gonna go down is we have
eight total players we're gonna do three
tournaments if you will
one being uh the first four people
first place second players will be
determined those two will carry over to
the final
third tournament where we will determine
the first
place
winner
magical
sounds awesome does that make any sense
it makes sense to me it makes sense to
me see if it makes sense to the audience
yes so again uh here's our uh
first two races here uh we're gonna
start off with four players you have
cali michael gadge and ben and then the
next race randy will jake and justin
first place second place will be
determined and they will
combined
into your four
player final championship race
and here we go first place uh excuse me
first player there on the right cali ben
gadge and michael on the left there uh
they're looking real tense it's gonna be
an interesting interesting race
now uh joey you are a uh very much
experienced extraordinaire mario kart
player yourself i'm gonna be referring
to you for a lot of the uh answers the
and questions that i uh will be giving
to you
any questions you have about what items
courses just let me know
you also have uh
knowledge on a lot of these uh players
and what kind of skills they possess is
that right uh to some extent yes that's
great that's all i haven't seen everyone
play
um but the ones i have they're probably
gonna be uh
some of the favorites
interesting well uh i think we're about
ready to kick this thing off
so uh
here we go uh so what's gonna go on here
is uh
we already got some uh some
some upsetting news here so
and what is that
so each
so as far as the course is being picked
each each racer will be able to pick
their own um
and then it'll randomize it from there
and looks like i see
we got the the mario kart 8 version of
rainbow road oh my god it is in space
look at this
so again there we have uh cali playing
as peach
ben is
wario gadge being oh we already have
difficulty with michael uh what just
happened there i can't tell you uh we
had a little communication error
i think we may have to uh re it's a good
thing this happened very very early in
the match well there you go we're gonna
have to we're gonna call that a uh a
fault start we're gonna have to
re-start that whole tournament well
that's unfortunate but you know things
happen uh a tire can blow out um someone
could uh need to use the restroom real
quick you know there's a variety of
things that can affect a uh race so so
first of all let's talk about the
brackets
in the first bracket right here we have
cali ben gadge and michael
and as far as i know uh cali placed
first in our preliminary tournament that
is correct we did have pollinate
preliminaries
preliminary preliminary uh yeah so what
can you tell me about cali
um
she is
probably one of the better players in
the office she's also very vocal
uh when it comes to whether or not
she gets second or third or anything
other than first
oh geez she's
already you might be able to hear a
couple things coming out uh from the
racer area
in the event that that doesn't happen
okay now do you know anything about ben
ben uh is wielding some shades
uh and he looks pretty threatening if i
do say something intimidation factor
very very much so i mean if you can't
see their eyes who knows what they're
gonna do yeah uh so again he's playing
as wario uh can you tell me anything
about this character
which character
uh combined wario along with you know
some of the other bigger characters is
uh is a heavyweight and they tend to
have a higher higher top speed lower
acceleration so they
you know it takes them a little while to
get up to that speed but once they're
there they can they can just cruise
along
um and as far as their drifting
capabilities it's a little a little more
slidy
so might be difficult depending on which
race uh which courses
uh we end up seeing very interesting
next we have gadge here
gadge is rocking roy uh koopa troopa
very similar to wario in that he's uh
he's a heavyweight but i
i believe uh i
don't know don't know the exact numbers
but i think he actually might be one of
the heavier ones
probably super heavyweights among those
classes okay okay
and michael is rocking rosalina
is there any uh stats you can uh tell me
on rosie rosalina despite being a woman
in this game she's actually also one of
the heavier ones get out because she's
probably she i think i believe she is
the tallest character if they were to
all stand up
in a row and that would make sense as
far as uh you know you said top speed is
is something to look for with heavy
weights but uh does her height is that
play in the factor of
possibly being able to see what's ahead
of you okay typically no okay
uh so yeah again we are uh about to cut
to the race i believe we had some uh
hiccups here in the start of the last
one um
and we're gonna get right into it uh how
how have you been liking mario kart you
you uh play a lot yourself i played love
eight on the wii u i haven't played that
much of the switch version but it's
looking pretty fun
uh the fact that each person can now get
their own screen
uh is
is key i think
right i myself tried out uh playing uh
split screen on the uh switch
screen itself that is very difficult uh
it works but it's real tough on the yeah
when you only have maybe three inches of
viewing space
okay well uh it looks like we're about
ready to go they're uh now voting for
the courses to be played at random uh
it's a voting process but uh i believe
we can we can cut to now the
game feed and see what's actually going
on here
uh
again if you're just joining us this is
uh our in-house
mario kart deluxe
tournament
we're back in it
already some smack talk is happening
two
one
and they all look slow looks like callie
and ben got the boost at the beginning
gadge and michael are a little bit
further behind both in third and fourth
place respectively
um but
everyone seems to be going everything
seems to be going pretty well except for
gadgets flying off the course right here
that's not what you want to happen
beginning stages of a race
uh so cali is in first place as usual um
and if you'll notice she's actually
carrying the banana behind her
protecting her from any shells or
um any other projectiles that may be
shot in her way very much a uh an old
time
uh
first place tactic for mario kart yeah
so she's cruising let's see whether or
not she actually oh she did not take the
shortcut here oh um but it seems to be
okay there's no there doesn't seem to be
any threat nearby
um yeah no one she's
cleared everyone by a good
good quarter of a mile maybe now tell me
more about this shortcut is that is that
something that uh is is a vital uh
route you want to take is is that going
to shave off some seconds uh the
shortcut that was i was mentioning is uh
close to the end of the round end of the
course and uh you kind of use the uh the
height oh ben uh tried to get that
corner but he fell off
that is a shame that's gonna put him in
sixth place um near the end of the
course there's a there's a high you have
a little bit of a high ground and if you
jump off of that and you can skip uh one
or two turns at the very end oh
that's a little risky because you can't
actually see where you land so you kind
of have to trust so let's see if gadget
right here will take it
uh no he does not he does not take it
gage is playing again the uh koopa
troopa
roy yeah who is uh
are there different classes as far as
weights like is there a super
heavyweight is there a headphone i
believe roy is a heavyweight and then
his brother um
i'm blanking on the name uh but he is
they all look alike yeah they all kind
of look like they have the they have the
shells in the back but he is rocking the
star right here
ooh let's hope that decides to use it
here to yeah clear the
clear the jump to make up for the time
lost after that unfortunate spill off
the track we're cutting back now to no
this is still him that was a little
deceiving no this is ben right here he
is in uh eighth place right here oh
that star threw me threw me off look
like they both have one looks like you
got the golden mushroom though so he can
runs over a banana
so as a mario kart 6 oh and that's gonna
be cali first place wow and you said
that's uh not too surprising not too
surprising uh-huh um as far as everyone
else
uh
ben
those shades are
are looking real great
cali giving some
oh now we have smack talking this is
unfortunate we're coming right back here
uh looks like everyone was a little bit
further behind
and that's going to be race one of three
more we got callie and gage taking the
advantage in the first round uh-huh um
with michael and ben getting uh i think
11th and 12th place respectively okay
it's gonna take a very uh
i don't want to say a miracle but it's
gonna take a couple good races for them
to catch up if they want to get advanced
in the second round it was
quite the difference there in in uh
in places wasn't it yeah 10th and 12th
those are different numbers from one
although they do have one in them uh
they're much further down
in the in the rankings okay so they're
gonna have to make uh quite the comeback
and that was again uh what were those
places uh respectively with the players
believe it was first place seventh place
for uh gauge and then ben and michael
were 11th and 12th respectively gotcha
so gadge is going to need to do some
work if he is expected to uh make it out
alive because again yeah as far as the
points go first place we'll get 15 and
then we'll go 12
10 or 9 i believe all the way down to 11
12 which are one and two points gotcha
so they have a long ways to go but they
can still do it gotcha
and we're off
cali with a uh very very great start
she's taking both the short or both the
boost off the shortcut right there wow
she's deciding to go on the top
or did she
she says it's not her normal she is now
complaining about her cart which is a
despite being in first place yeah she
has all the complaints in the world
first place problems i say i would say
so too and she decides to go up up on
the left to get the boosts there avoid
the cable car along the way
and again uh i think uh some of the
rules that were set uh were that uh all
players are to be using these standard
loadouts for both carts and if they
decide to use bikes right
well that's great hope we got michael in
second but he does get hit by a couple
of uh
straight fireballs there
michael throwing some uh throwing some
smack
a lot of smack going on he's inked but
he decides to go for the shortcut and he
makes both of them
and then
up on up on top of the uh
tent he goes
oh very well put together track oh he's
you see right there he could have
actually knocked uh roy who is gadge
right here
if uh he holds a banana behind him sure
sure
more precise if you will but gadge
decides to you know speed through and oh
he just barely makes it
some sheer talent right there if i do
say so myself he is in third he's going
to need to work his way
towards him
is in fourth place
no uh this is uh actually uh a
look-alike i believe joey
this is uh this is not peach oh that is
rosalina
sorry for my mistake it's okay
we are there
so with two items you know in in mario
kart 8 deluxe uh they now have double
item boxes which i see uh we'll give you
two
either in this case for cali a coin and
a banana
so you can kind of predict or uh you
know utilize the the strategy more so if
you have a an idea of what your next
item is going to be
we got michael very interesting fourth
place trying to try to close some space
out between uh
between gadge i believe who is in third
oh no ben is in there no he isn't second
now wow so if he can avoid that red
shell it looks like he is gonna be close
oh my god
joey
explain to me what just happened there
that was
insane
that was very close so uh ben
coming around the the very final turns
course had a red shell right on his tail
he used up all his mushrooms but he was
able to just even getting hit by it he
was far enough ahead in second place
to close out the match there
so that that will get him quite a few
points
and as you know he did get you know one
of the the last places in the last round
but
he's back up he's slightly back more
back up on top now that's good yeah that
last race seemed to be a lot more
tighter i think people are now you know
loosening up uh their tires so to speak
and uh you know a little a little cheery
there on the on the far left michael uh
what should we do we're just having the
music for this one i hate oh yeah like
that having some fun there that's
they're saying turn up the music but
we're not going to do that we got them
picking the courses now let's see what
we got
so again i was calling for uh first
place this is big blue oh big blue so
this is the uh f-zero track i was gonna
say that's familiar and uh
compared to most of the of the other
tracks this one is actually a single
race all the way through to the end
there are no laps
oh
oh wow and there there is a lot of stuff
going on so you have uh little
boosts right here you got the uh the
coin strips on the side
that would you just run right over them
they'll give you maybe about four or
five coins stay on it the whole time
very reminiscent of the actual f-zero
track we're zooming in here on ben i
believe that is
that that i believe that is ben and ben
was unfortunately robbed of his first
place
position
last race we'll see if he can
make some
lead here all right we got them going
over the coin strips up he does have 10
coins so he does get a little that
little uh boost there of speed um yeah
tell me more about these coins so coins
uh cali has nine and what
what
you can look there on his face he looks
like a seventh place
player that's a seventh place smile
right there that is you know it happens
he says he used to be drift king but
apparently not in that
so explain to me now who we got here as
far as uh uh our
prospective first and second players
um i believe kelly
even if she gets
last place here she might actually be
able to uh
to advance to the next girl carry on um
as far as second place as far as the
second person to get through next round
uh it looks really close ben took second
place in or ben took first and second in
both the last races
and uh gage he might need to to knock
him down a little bit further past at
maybe fourth or fifth place in order to
advance
so it's going to come down to those two
as far as the the next person to go
gotcha it looks like the race i believe
has just kicked off
and we're going to uh
in a quick second
once
uh
the feed is in and it's it
there we go heard right is the sunshine
airport oh wow
and so this this has us racing through
the uh the airport
it's
you know i
i'm not an faa expert but this seems
like a very interesting uh
race to have here so we have a little
spiral going up into the air and then
coming back down onto the runway
so we got cali and ben both in first and
second place respectively uh gadge not
too far behind he pulls up in third and
michael a little bit a little bit
lagging behind insects but everyone gets
hit by a lightning bolt
uh to my understanding we had some uh
technical problems in the back so if you
uh were watching and wanted to know
exactly who won uh the last race that
was gonna be that's ben
ben was first callie was second
and
remind remind me the other i know
michael was in seventh in the last one
and then what was that was in third
gadget is in third right there so gadge
right here he is in six he actually just
got his bomb taken away oh no by a by a
boo and so booze are new to mario kart 8
or marco ate the looks excuse me gotcha
um he's trying to make up the time with
a couple of mushrooms
uh
he's got a star right behind his behind
him on his tail look at that he's gonna
want to watch out for that he sure is
cali once again is uh she's cruising
along in first place
no one in sight behind her wow
we'll see if she can keep that going oh
then he's close he's getting a little
close he's trying to uh
close some space on this he's got some
green shells he's got the green [ __ ]
three green shells
as well as a red shell i don't know if
he should be holding on to his green
shells too much because i was thinking
that
but the thing is he is uh he is in
second place which which if he stays
there it could guarantee him
uh the second round
gotcha so what we're really looking for
is uh
oh the second place turnout right
between gadgets
oh my god a brutal setback
hot diggity damn
so it looks like it look it sounded as
if ben was closing in on cali with the
red shell
oh
mama joey this is looking real tense
trying to go past the luggage
and oh
there you go ben with the uh
the photo finish
let's see if we can take a look at the
uh the results screen for this
we'll have to cut to that in a second
there might be some prep but holy god
mother mary joey
that was a tight
then very close clutching his necklace
yeah clutching his oh it's and it's
the team spirit and the appreciation
is adorable
wow
so that's going to be kelly in first
behind her is
ben
janka
and he's going to be
her and cali are going to be the two
we're going to advance into our final
race
uh but that's going to be after our
upcoming race which is coming in the
second we have our contestants filing in
in a sec um but cali uh why don't we
have her come up on uh the uh
hot seat here and ask her a couple
questions um
though um this one's go quickly
uh gadget ben valian effort gash made it
really close at the end he could have
taken
possibly could have taken the uh second
place in this match but you know good
for them for uh keeping it competitive
and a very charming thing to say i agree
wholeheartedly but here we have uh first
place callie from the last uh series of
races there kelly what was your secret
um i picked the court so i picked
rainbow road um first and that one won
i was the only racer in that bracket who
wasn't a heavy um and so i had better
drifting capabilities and so i was able
to outdrift them yes because as we know
rainbow road especially the wii u
version
is is it twisted
both figuratively and literally a
twisted map it is a it's a turn fest if
you will it's there's a lot of drifting
involved and that's uh
my preferred way to race so
yeah that's what i went with
at any moment were you afraid
no
wow that confidence right there
maybe for a second when ben was doing
really well on big blue
but
nah okay well
uh about the next you're a little
worried
okay well uh is there anyone uh in the
uh the next lineup of players that are
are you worried about randy for sure
randy they're on the right he is oh look
at that intimidation
he's watching
uh as we get things going there in a
second uh so actually let's let's do
before they start a quick rundown of
their uh characters that they'll be
playing sure uh we have randy here on
the right playing a shy guy we have
justin playing as villager
male 1
okay
jake
boy villager is the light blue yoshi
interesting we'll see if that color has
any effect
and it certainly matches the shirt okay
and will
playing as green classic uh yoshi i
wonder if you know these two are gonna
butt heads being the same type of anime
model almost the same height too
fun fact will actually uh placed
he uh made the qualifiers because i
wasn't able to
to do
i was unable to attend
so hopefully he'll uh erase in my name
and do me do me a solid okay well cali
thank you so much for uh
joining us and giving a little uh
tips and tricks on how you were able to
achieve your first place uh we look
forward to seeing you race in the final
tournament tournament
looks like uh they're starting off uh
moomoo farm um i believe this was 64.
was it the 64 version
maybe not 64. but uh there were 164. we
will see cows we will see a groundhog or
uh
we will see the monty moles popping up
and we'll also see which one of these
players is the best at milken first and
second whoo
uh one thing to know is uh there are no
heavyweights in this ah in this group
whatsoever good eye um so we'll we'll
see possibly uh fewer sliding you know
fewer instances of them sliding off the
edge
a little more tight controls oh looks
like shy guy and yoshi are butting heads
a little bit and tight controls is
definitely something you would want in
this because i'm seeing a lot of uh
unruly pesky gophers
popping out in the track do you know
anything about these gophers joey yes
the monty moles or moles uh they'll
they'll be digging through the the
ground popping up a couple times but
though they uh the racers will be able
to use their uh their trails that they
leave behind as uh boosts so as you can
see here if randy will take the uh nope
he misses it all together but right here
he's able to jump off it get a little
speed boost
there uh comfortably in second place
not sure who's in first oh justin
with the villager holding the banana
behind him he has a second banana on
deck just in case he gets hit by a shell
here he's trying to navigate through
these uh these pesky cows look at the
wind flapping through his hair drops a
banana picks up a second item
which will be a coin he does have 10
coins so he does have a slight that
slight speed boost but he tries to go
for the the monty mole jump and misses
the first one gets the second one
and it looks like uh
so looks randy is right behind him on
his tail but blue yoshi right here
who is jake is in fifth place
gets hit by a red shell and
zooms ahead
his arch nemesis brother takes it from
him
i believe so so that would be uh justin
in first randy behind him
will and then jake fourth place in the
in the match
third place within the group here
wow that was that was a that was an
interesting title so that was one of
four races will be jumping into the
second race
looks like randy is uh they're picking
the matches right now and it looks like
he might have gotten dragon driftway
is that am i correct to say that guys
so that is one of the new dlc tracks
that was released oh fantastic couple
years ago
from mario kart 8 and it is uh it is a
twisting
it's pretty twisted oh wow it looks
very similar to the uh the
version of rainbow road gotcha
and they are off
will without he misses the boost so does
justin so they're fourth and sixth place
here
so dragon driftway is a is i feel a lot
a lot harder than the uh the rainbow
road mostly because if you can see uh
they go in and out between these
these little pagodas sections oh um
shaped like a dragon oh and it's a it
can be a little bit difficult to see
because there's a lot of brown going
along there's a lot of twisting turning
going upside down
um but if you see jake right here uh
taking this
who's
hopefully with the mushroom uh he wants
to be very careful just to make sure to
boost along straight away just like that
get a couple jumps in along the way oh
he's got a green shell but he's not
protecting himself here uh oh looks like
he got out right before red shell was
about to hit him you may have just
reminded him yeah
randy's in first place uh got a banana
protecting his butt
so it really seems like at the moment
randy and justin are really kind of
butting heads here yeah well actually
justin's in fifth uh trailing behind
will
oh that's not will i'm sorry excuse me
that is jake here and justin decides to
go over the grass hopefully uh
didn't
lose too much speed there
okay
mushrooms to help him out in this corner
but he is in seventh place
seventh place that's not too great we'll
see if he can
change mushroom and a star on dick but
he falls off
randy uh
comfortably in first
place will says he has not played this
track before which is gonna be uh
you don't want that going into a race
looks like a first place
first place got hit by both a lightning
bolt and a blue shell oh
sounds like jake is uh coming for first
place with a red shell and a mushroom oh
and he knocks him no he didn't he held
that mushroom looks like he had a
mushroom in first place oh i'm sorry a
banana to protect himself in first place
that is bananas
and he has a green shell and a mushroom
oh and a banana i'm sorry i'm getting my
mushrooms and bananas mixed up here i'm
just a little hungry yeah you're making
me hungry
hungry to see what this turnout's going
to be
we got just in second place
trying to catch up trying to catch up to
randy here a couple bananas and a green
shell might not be able to do it so he
just throws it behind him and he takes
second place while randy takes first
looks like
well as we do know that
will
more or less
is a filler
and that is a shame but that's why
you're here because you are
an expert on your car if you will
you can say okay but you've but you felt
the craving of the course
the smell of the yeah rubber oh looks
like randy is uh it sounds as if he is
trying to
throw a wrench into all these problems
he's getting into justin's head oh god
choosing dragon driftwood again
now there are no limits to how many
times they can each pick a course oh
gosh that is cruel so if they get it
again that could be in randy's favor but
it sounds like
it was something else everyone everyone
breathed a sigh of relief
right it seems like uh randy is not
afraid to get his hands dirty
what we got here uh wario mountain wario
mountain i didn't know he had a mountain
yeah he he bothered with the money that
he made from uh the colosseum oh from
the 64 version and right here again
similar to big blue
it is one one race all the way down to
the bottom so you're really going to
want to know these these races yes so
they're telling me there's plenty of
shortcuts plenty of alternate routes you
can take oh uh the first shortcut is
coming up here in a couple of turns okay
uh we'll see if anyone is risky enough
to take it randy
seems like he could
randy is
possibly drunk i didn't see him with uh
cj flask
uh decides to not take it randy also
decides not to take it justin decides to
not take it maybe he will
nope he also skips it too oh considering
that they're all
within the top four spots it's a good
it's a good decision to keep it kind of
close don't risk anything too soon sure
sure uh will with the uh four or i'm
sorry the three shells three red shells
and three mushrooms on deck oh that's
that's in pretty would you say so so
he's got a lot of firepower um
i believe that uh now would be a good
time oh he uses it on the cpu
um but he he'll he'll see
we'll see if we can get close enough to
make it effective on the other three
races gotcha
so we got jake actually oh he is i think
i saw him jump on a shortcut there if
you would call it that it looked like
some
he was going off the slopes yeah looks
like he uh was able to speed through the
snow a little bit
avoid some of the trees and looks like
we have a blue shell coming up
uh jake decides to pull sonny bono there
he gets red shield
bananaed
he's gonna he's gonna want to make up
maybe possibly take some of those
shortcuts if there are any more randy is
he pulls ahead in first but looks like
it's neck and neck right
here we got we got a blooper spraying a
little bit of ink on the side now the
ink actually
in addition to taste good in addition to
it tasting good and reducing your
visibility it does actually make you
slide around a little bit so oh so it's
kind of a good thing
i would say if if you like uh taking
turns into walls it can be a good thing
oh okay but you want to avoid it mostly
so randy got the uh the sound the sound
thing i forget like name is what and he
uses it
oh god
wow
that's first for randy
that's third for justin's jake gets
second that was something that i've
you've never seen that i haven't seen
that before aw do tell what exactly did
we witness pulling up on the second to
last curve randy had a uh a little sound
bomb which basically creates a sound
wave in the short radius around you okay
uh destroying any projectiles and
knocking anyone out so he was able to
use it right as a red shell was going to
hit him and also knock away jake into
second place oh my and in addition to
that everyone got hit by a lightning
bolt right at that same time so there
was no way for him to recuperate and
maybe throw a shell at him when the
lightning bolt just destroys it all wow
again randy playing dirty and cali
seemed to be she was she was she was
accurate in saying that he's someone to
worry about oh gosh
that is super interesting so i believe
that race was
first
just or jake actually took second on
that even though justin was close on his
tail in third place
and will again
somewhere in the in the back
yeah in the rear end of the pack it
seems unfortunate uh for will because it
doesn't seem like he'll be able to uh
do anything yeah he may not be able to
advance but he will be able to play uh
play
what's up what's the what's the term for
just ruin everyone else's day oh sure he
could uh take some revenge out
if you will now uh so
as far as our our placings currently we
have one more uh map left one more
course
where are we standing we have uh randy's
is in first i believe i believe randy's
in first okay justin is in second okay
i want to say he's in second by a very
slim margin and jake is right behind him
okay so for our viewers really
want to keep an eye on uh jake and
justin who are battling for second
because
as we know how this tournament is gonna
work out uh first and second
players in this race uh of the four will
be advancing into our final
race that's right which currently has
cali and ben from the previous lineup of
uh races and now i believe we are
picking the next map
but uh it's unclear
oh it's okay
except they're uh rejoining the room
okay back shortly to the feed uh one
thing i did want to note is that
even though will might not be able to
advance
he can he can pick and choose who he
wants to attack
um so if he decides to stay a little bit
further further in the back
he might be able to you know
he might be able to collect those uh
stars those lights the stars the
lightnings the three red shells the the
boos the you know the even the blue
shell sure sure you know he can decide
if he gets a blue shell while on the
back of the pack he can decide who he
wants to throw to depending on who's in
first at the time wow and it's
interesting to think that
excuse me
he could kind of single out some of
these players could he can be the
deciding factor in who gets first second
and third wow that's a lot of power if
you really think about it um
who do you think
as far as perspective uh lineup here so
that we have randy on the right who's
currently in first justin there and jake
who are
uh
i looks like i got the numbers here uh
standing currently is uh justin uh
actually
it's the lineup as you see it first on
the right second third and fourth
uh
and they'll be
they'll be racing once to decide who of
these two will advance
wow so yeah it definitely looks like uh
justin and jake will have to uh
you know as they are friends they might
have to pull out a knife and
backstab one another in order to advance
each other backshell thank you
very nice
but um yeah so as far as the sandies
looks like justin
has a 37 points here and jake
a little bit further behind than i
originally thought with 28.
so as
as far as standings go jake is going to
have to put justin way behind in order
for him to have enough points to advance
[Music]
with with a nine point difference he
needs
at least to get in second with uh justin
to be maybe around fifth or sixth
um looks like we got the mushroom
kingdom stage here
very reminiscent of stool castle a
little reminiscent here of a royal
raceway
no it is royal racing excuse me actually
it looks identical now it is identical
oh my god
all right go everyone's staying pretty
close together uh first through fourth
here with randy uh again being in first
but justin speeds ahead
randy in fourth that's very unlike randy
he might be drinking again he crashes
into a wall here
again earlier i saw randy drinking a
gallon of vodka pure vodka uh we'll see
if that has some sort which is funny
because he usually drinks two yeah every
morning i notice that um as far as his
his placement goes he really doesn't
have too much to worry about uh
considering that jake is a little bit
further behind
but if he does get last place by
like some magical forces happening in on
this course uh he could be in trouble
but i i feel like he's a solid enough
racer to
get with at least within the top half
he's currently in fourth he is
definitely currently in fourth
but he's packing six red shells we'll
see how he uses them that's three that's
it rob snow six he's got three more
oh wait i'm an idiot
i'm just seeing numbers oh i think andy
gets two of them just shaved off by that
bullet bill and it looks like there's a
blue shell coming in zoning in on
whoever's in first
i'm sorry jake your time in first place
may be up and he slows down a little bit
oh that's hoping to catch whoever's in
second place
but justin was a little bit further
behind and he knocks him out with a red
shell to add insult to injury
and he takes first place with jake
trying to make up that lost time giggity
giggity
justin now taking first
and we are on the last lap
so we got a blooper coming in getting
inking everyone and also lightning bolts
uh the cpu knows what's up that's a
double trouble
all right randy with three mushrooms
here and he could use it to speed ahead
of will who has a piranha plant
oh randy
getting off the track there because he's
confident his mushrooms will oh but he
slowed down a little bit jay coming in
first which is oh no he doesn't he oh no
he got second
this is gonna be very this is gonna be
really really close everyone is with
first second and third are within maybe
a couple seconds of each other justin
runs off the grass on into the grass a
little bit
but he does have a green shell behind to
protect him oh he used it sure did
protect him he is right around
get that bird off the track because
justin is taken first
behind him
oh wow working for cut into this we
should probably cut to uh the speed
because i want to see who is going to
take second
and who is it all right let's add up the
points see who we have
15.
what did uh randy get 12 uh
12 10.
we're telling up who's gonna take
second not enough
i didn't say so it appears as if uh we
had a little connection there earlier on
so we wanted to make sure we got the
scores down before we advance to the
next race
um so we have nick margarita
tallying the points and we will find out
officially even though it's uh based on
their reactions it's uh
we might already know
joey i'm
i'm being told it's a tie
then it's a timer
we got to get some
randy
what's going on here
justin and randy looks like justin and
randy are our top two
okay
well it makes sense to me as justin uh
justin well so the the confusion here
was that
oddly enough our first and second
players
were tied so you guys you two are
actually equals
i was really nervous going into this
uh-huh because i think out of all of the
tournaments so far this is probably one
of the more balanced ones jake has put
in a lot of hours will as a wild card
and randy
so we raced in the office we raced with
mario carty came out we've been racing
since this one and sometimes randy beats
me sometimes i beat randy it's i feel
like it was pretty balanced back and
forth that's a slight exaggeration i
beat justin all the time um and today he
got he got lucky but i think really the
the the real competition here is us
against cali right i think the only
competition is who's going to come in
second that's the big question yeah i
mean she's not here we should totally
just sabotage her she is here now she
just walked in so oh wait she's coming
in right now did you even say
yeah wow you guys are really going to
play it dirty huh
are you telling me that you're going to
team up on on cali to bring her if there
were abilities if we could do that yes i
would 100 do it there are ways you can
do that though you could sabotage cali
somebody in the race well not saying but
you can't
there are methods to target first place
you know make sure whoever is in second
doesn't get hit by whoever's in third
you can kind of communicate that to each
other not saying that i endorse that but
it is something that is possible
considering that we're all in the same
room together so the point is really
just to gun for kelly when she's in
first place and make sure
that she gets knocked down
based on her performance so far that
might evening out for all you guys
um
is it 2v2 so we're not doing any four of
you four matches oh we're doing 4v4
isn't it this is it right this is it not
4v4
what is mario this is if not 4v4 this is
sorry for four player free-for-all yeah
that's right and right now we have our
final four races with
as you can see there cali justin ben and
randy it's gonna be heated it's gonna be
nasty gentlemen thank you for uh giving
your input on those last races
but now we're getting to it
because oh dude pull that out again
yeah okay
depending on
the winner of this they will be
crown champion
wow ort queen
wait champion or queen what i thought
you said king will not will not be king
they will be crowned
i'm super excited to see where this
crown will be landing on which noggin of
these four so so
who do you believe rob
we'll take this
well
i'm hearing a lot of players even randy
and justin who are uh known to uh talk
smack they both seem pretty terrified of
cali so if i were a betting man i would
put
a hundred clams on cali
but it's a lot of plants a lot of
seafood a lot of bivalves right there
it is now
where do you think where do you think
this crown
is gonna land i
you're thinking i'm thinking you're
really thinking
my first instinct would be to say go
with the favorite
you know she has proven herself worthy
several times over in the office
but after talking to justin and randy
you know i feel like they're they're
cooking something up oh they're cooking
they might be cooking and and as far as
ben goes you know he seems to be uh
i feel like he has something of his own
yeah those uh those shades he's wearing
are
oh wow and look at that charm i i there
is something about ben that's that's an
underdog isn't there i mean
in in the in the first round with him uh
you know he he got pretty close with
gash
uh
taking like second and third place you
know them switching off a little bit
already we're having some disagreement
on the voting process for the
for the races up ahead they're voting on
the first race
and it looked like justin raised his
arms in triumph because
i can only imagine that he picked
something yeah something that he's happy
with
maybe uh
it
oh tick-tock clock that is a really
awesome uh mario 64. no
this is a ds version it's the ds version
excuse me
i'm just thinking of mario 64 because i
adore that game
okay we got a lot of moving parts this
does take place inside the giant clock
presumably um so we got gears we got
faces we got little
bells going off all at the same time
nothing's going callie with the question
where is everyone oh callie is talking
matt's max she's asking where is
everyone else
so she's she's holding first place she's
got a banana and she had two bananas to
deter both the red shells that were
thrown at her yao keeping her in first
place and she does have a bomb
looks like she decided to just uh let it
go as opposed to keeping it behind her
and it worked in her favor wow
she you can keep a bomb behind her
she both she at once believed that she
couldn't but now that she has this
information which is funny because
she somehow got a bomb in first place
i'm not sure how that happens
but
you're hearing hacks that's
that is a rough word to toss around but
it's being tossed because it's a heated
heated race already looks like ali
coasting in
ben coming in or he is close behind her
in second place with a red shell on deck
and he decides to hold on to it for a
little bit interesting we'll see how
that plays out or without a shell or any
banana to protect her
he takes a couple of boosts right here
decides not to go off the jump but
everyone gets hit by the lightning yao
randy who uh placed uh what oh jeez what
do you place last match i thought you
were placed first oh interesting or
actually i believe they were tied
but regard
regardless regardless he's in fourth
that's not a good spot to be in this
in this four player race cali is still
leading we have ben uh the underdog of
the story and second
and justin just gets hit looks like he
wants to uh stay a little bit further
behind there's a
blue shell coming in
uh oh
profanity she is terrified he is inked
but it doesn't matter because
she'll miss me oh callie lets a red show
go and then she
lets another
that's gonna set him off and she still
takes second ben the underdog of the
story is in first place
if you saw that right there yeah so come
and describe it to me
coming around the last turn
ben manages to go in front of cali
after her getting hit by the blue shell
and so he only had one banana to hold on
to behind him
callie had two red shells
she used one it hit the banana destroyed
it he was a sitting duck but somehow he
went over the ramp
red shell might have lost its uh its
tracking i believe it hit did the did
that second red shell hit you
past me it flew right back
straight by him he zoomed in first
again we're the top spot in this round
it's an underdog story and i am very
surprised but yeah that's going to put
cali in second and that's not a good
spot for our second
is just as bad as third and fourth here
it really is there will be no second
place winner that's right
there are second place losers third
place losers and fourth place losers as
the great ricky bobby once said you've
ain't first your last
wise words and it looks like we have
rainbow road
from
n64 version oh the classic
wow
oh wow we're we're having some
disagreement here on
on the track cali says this is the worst
one ben says it's the best and that is
interesting yet cali's in first
and then is dropping down in places
there so this is very interesting to see
if he has any underdog trying to avoid
that chain chomp there right bouncing
around on the course
we got randy in third randy and justin
pretty close
and once again uh this seems to be a
theme in every every round that we've
had
um or every bracket that we've had
actually is that uh this is also in
addition to big blue and wario mountain
uh a single race so there are no
there are no lapses here
um one thing that people have always
said about
or i've heard some complaints about this
rainbow road being too short oh is it
and so that you really have to be on top
of everything when you play this one
because you can very easily fall behind
in the fourth and fifth and sixth as
cali is being shown right here
oh no she got hit by a couple of red
shells
dropped down the third
justin and ben took first and second and
looks like ben whoo
oh no callie's in fourth this is
this is unlike cali joey and it looks
like this ben is looking to be in very
good shape here he's coming around the
final stretch and he
will take it the red shell doesn't
matter because
wow
ben the late bloomer the underdog
and uh i am unsure of what other places
we have here because we keep cutting out
of it every single person here
cannot believe what they just saw what
they just experienced
describe it to me joey what exactly just
happened
man
[Music]
maybe until two thirds of the way
she dropped down the third i believe
after getting hit by a couple of shells
which is not too bad
but then after that she just kept
getting bombarded by more red shells and
more bananas
while ben stayed in first he wrestled
with uh with justin a little bit
you know they they
butted heads with a banana a couple
times and he was able to secure first
place oh my god
you know this is really interesting
kylie looks a little upset there on the
right uh
i'm not sure what's going on i mean not
a good look for her this is not good
wow
all right i believe in my life
which which race is this is this going
to be
this is the electrode the the
disco themed oh i like disco which is
actually this is one of my favorite
courses oh fun you know it's it's it's a
little bit difficult there's a lot of
stairs a lot of bumps along the way
there are a couple different paths that
they can take
i don't know but aesthetically i feel
like this is one of the most satisfying
courses to be on so as even though
we may see some disagreements we'll get
some cool music out of it a heck yeah
i'm into it
now
explain to me where where are we at
right now is is ben in first place no we
got uh oh actually yeah he i'm sorry of
the total rate amount of uh uh races
we've had so far this is this is number
is this number three or four is this
last one this is the third race that's
what i thought so
he's he knows his own value
he knows his own point values himself he
is in first place by a healthy healthy
margin
um he's still in first he's got four
bananas oh god protecting him he was
flexing them
who has a red shell she could
uh otherwise we got randy and justin
here fighting for
third okay looks like kelly and ben
decide to part ways um cali with the
pink side ben with the green so they
won't they won't knock into each other
quite yet until the the final jump
around this lap okay um let's see if
kelly decides to use that red shell
anytime soon though
justin has actually taken the green side
he is uh closing in on both randy and
ben
[Music]
and looks like kelly uh sped ahead into
first place not so long oh and she
is back in first
[Music]
there's some disagreement here
there there's some disagreements about
who hit who hit whom gotcha but everyone
gets hit here once again by a lightning
bolt
cpu trying to keep it even
trying to keep it fair
i for one hate
lightning bolts cali decides to go pink
side once again ben decides to follow
her
hoping that he will get some kind of
weapon but he gets a coin unfortunately
he has he has one more chance to get a
weapon oh it's hit by a red shell
no it's a double whammy for ben setting
him in fourth looks like randy is the
the last
three green shells but cali
is far enough ahead to take first
justin and randy might have to battle
for it here randy with a few mushrooms
but he over
he overcompensates on that final turn
crashes into a wall and gets third place
[Music]
ben says there's still one race and
gosh darn it he is absolutely correct
wow we uh we have a fairly diverse uh
board here joey
wow you know as the mario kart way
things are
changing directions we had our underdog
get crushed in this last race
as expected so the final track
is the one that's going to be it's going
to decide it right here
the final the final shebang
uh
looks like they're
they're cheering for baby park but i'm
actually lost what is it uh cali
oh no
he
got r or all four of them got rainbow
road looks like describe it to me
oh not just any rainbow road
the super the super nintendo rainbow
road okay unlike the wii u version it is
completely flat there are tons of swamps
everywhere
ben ben had yelled i'm screwed or
something along the lines of that
explain to me why ben is going to have a
hard time on this map so he is the only
heavyweight within this group oh which
means that he's going to have to be a
lot more careful taking these turns i
see just right here he was he almost
fell off he didn't but callie actually
actually skipped
oh
a lot of smack talking
going on in this last race all right you
can see ben is being a little bit more
cautious you know he's not drifting uh
too much he's actually taking turns
straight you know without drifting
see as you can see he slows down a
little bit and even though uh drifting
is always
drifting is uh ideal yes he's still in
third he's
which is i believe uh of the two or out
of the four here that is
second
so it looks like ben and callie still
butting heads here callie is
not too far away from ben ben closing in
he's got red shell he lets it go callie
blocks it with the green shell
whoo ben he he's he is being really
cautious on those turns
justin's uh is bobbing his head as if
he's having a bad time because eighth
place is not first joey oh nice ben
actually
he uh
that sequence of events right here ben
taking that shortcut using his boost to
get into a sec or get a little bit
closer to cali yeah at the same time
kelly getting hit by the blue shell
which
on the way to her knock been off as well
oh gosh so
this is the most nervous i've ever been
callie says this is the most nervous
she's ever been
well i'm not gonna lie here joey i'm a
little nervous myself because oh my
god is and oh she almost teeters off but
she does not looks like ben taking that
turn a little bit more adventurously
here and he's gonna go through the
center oh
take that shortcut doesn't matter
because cali takes first place
ben's gonna follow with second
as the underdog let's see if that's
enough though you did not get second i
did [ __ ]
no oh but i did
so callie wasn't kelly thought she got
this boy won by one point
no this sounds like
no
an enormous upset
get
out of here joey been clutching his
necklace
now joey
i'm a little flustered in the heat of
this
crazy energy that's billowing around the
room it's it's flooding up
i'm hot
i am confused explain to me what
happened joey
looks like ben won
ben
the underdog of this
tournament holy guacamole
that is truly unexpected now we have
here our winner congratulations ben
thank you very much oh please put that
on top of your you get to wear the
winners crown how does that feel ben
feels like i'm wearing a wonderful crown
made out of plastic and dreams gosh and
your shades really match
the crowns they're so well they're
something indeed well congratulations
ben oh thank you thank you
callie how you how you holding up over
there you the expected
winner the the queen in the room
somewhat got dethroned how are you
feeling
second is not that bad
though this is the worst day of my life
oh i had a good time
so ben let's let's talk to you first
about sure yeah
your race is here okay um
during the first uh during the first
bracket you had
it was very close between you and gash
it really was uh right up until the end
it was uh an interesting time i started
off my first race finishing in like 10th
wow
yeah it was it was real rough and i
somehow managed to to get it all
together and come back and
yeah and i know you were you were racing
as wario did that
did you feel that that had any uh impact
on your your placement at all
i feel like uh wario is the the chosen
son of of everyone and he should be in
all of our hearts the one that we all
care about the most wario he's great
i like him a lot are you wearing two
pairs of glasses here
you tell me oh
the true colors of the winner of our
internet in office willa back up in
office tournament there it is again
we're coming right back to the bracket
there ben congratulations again callie
i'm sorry you have any other last words
i just want to say i want to be nice and
nice and good sorry yeah i'm sorry for
interrupting you please continue yeah
congratulations uh
callie
how how are you doing i mean
we'll probably do this again whether it
be uh live or not but
don't look at me
so
i hope you don't take any of this out on
me kali uh you played very strongly and
uh i applaud your uh competitive smack
talking here in the studio this is all i
have in this world oh boy no i'm fine
it's fine
you i'm glad that we had a healthy good
race yeah no it was a lot of fun because
like it's really boring the first one
where i was just kind of like in front
the whole time yeah yeah this was much
more exciting oh yeah definitely being
at first is is never interesting
i feel like oh no but it's no it isn't
it feels you in the the open road
clutching onto a banana behind you yeah
thinking about life everything
everything now
i don't know what to do with my life so
i gotta get good at it you gotta get
good and come back and i will gladly
pass off this crown whenever you beat me
again oh okay listen to that that was
very good sportsmanship i like that a
lot i cannot see that happening if this
was uh switched
oh oh is that so
that's possible or if randy or justin
was up here because randy randy and
justin uh you know i to be honest
they would scare me in first place i
wonder what with that power what they
would actually do
but i feel like
i'm really glad that neither of them
beat me because then i would definitely
be fired oh wow
i would just yell a lot i can't yell at
ben though i'm not been forever it's
true
and you know what it again is a
well-deserved the underdog of the story
ladies and gentlemen ben
jonker well
that's gonna do it for this in-office
tournament
i had a great time and i hope you had a
great time watching
thank you guys thank you again ben and
callie uh callie and nick margarith
putting this on and in the back uh
richard lee and john luke cepcke put a
lot of time and effort joey thank you so
much for co-hosting i'm so sorry you did
not get to play this time it is okay
because uh what happened
i'm just glad i was able to experience
it from this side you know give my input
and uh watch as
the fir the number one seed was uh taken
down
yeah by a point
it was by applying by one point this is
very true and the smack talk arises once
again it's a big point though
well you two we'll have to save it for
next time
thank you guys again for watching and
that's gonna do it for us
take care
and fly
into the weekend
you